[Musica]
uno dei fenomeni che digitalizzazione e
tecnologia hanno radicalmente
trasformato e totale cambiamento dei
punti di contatto tra utenti e servizi
molti di voi ricorderanno come la musica
oi viaggi venivano acquistati prima
dell'era digitale
quando essenzialmente l'abitudine a
quella di recarsi fisicamente presso
negozio di dischi un'agenzia di viaggi
oggi viceversa siamo tutti completamente
abituati ad ascoltare la nostra musica
preferita in streaming a ricevere
suggerimenti per il nostro prossimo
viaggio o contenuti digitali
direttamente dai social network in
qualsiasi momento da qualsiasi luogo
istantaneamente ora l'evoluzione sta
toccando un altro ambito che coinvolge
tutti noi
la salute è dunque il momento è arrivato
per invertire i punti di contatto anche
tra pazienti e servizi sanitari per
inquadrare questa trasformazione vorrei
condividere con voi alcuni casi reali
dei pazienti seguiti tramite
telemedicina antonio per esempio si è
recentemente sottoposto a un intervento
cardiochirurgico per il quale necessita
di costante monitoraggio nel post
intervento infatti il rischio di
ricaduta e complicanze
significativamente alto e tuttavia tali
fenomeni di aggravamento possono essere
identificati sei rilevati in anticipo
oggi antonio sta utilizzando
autonomamente una serie di dispositivi
aiuti per monitorare i propri livelli di
pressione arteriosa e tracciato
dell'elettrocardiogramma la simmetria il
peso eccetera da parte di un'equipe di
medici a distanza una app mobile in
forno antonio di quando e come
effettuare le misurazioni dei parametri
vitali durante la giornata e un'equipe
di medici e costantemente dedicata a
controllare e verificare che non ci
siano anomalie o criticità sui valori di
tali parametri vitali
tutto ciò consentendo ntonio di
trascorrere serenamente la propria
convalescenza a casa così come per marco
marco soffre di una broncopatia
ostruttiva per la quale necessita
frequente
mente di misurare la propria capacità
respiratoria tradizionalmente marco
dovrebbe quasi una volta al mese
prenotare un appuntamento presso una
struttura recarsi effettuare il test
attendere l'esito i risultati consultare
il medico eccetera oggi viceversa
marco può effettuare un test
spirometrici anche una volta al giorno
ottenendo una refertazione istantanea e
avvalendosi di strumenti altamente
professionali ma a basso impatto
economico
questi sono alcuni esempi di pazienti
che si possono sottoporre prestazioni
diagnostiche sanitarie in modo semplice
rimanendo a casa attraverso dispositivi
altamente professionali e avvalendosi di
un'intera equipe di medici che è
costantemente a disposizione per un
consulto i pazienti infatti in questi
casi vengono contattati qualora emergano
situazioni critiche o segnali anomali
rispetto i valori che costantemente ai
dati che costantemente fluiscono verso
la centrale di controllo
a questo punto vorrei condividere con
voi prefetti essenziali indotti dalla
trasformazione nel comportamento comune
dei pazienti e nell'inversione dei punti
di contatto paziente medico e per far
questo ho preso ispirazione da un famoso
film ecc adams della scena in cui mister
arthur trasmette a patch adams questa
meravigliosa intuizione di guardare
sempre oltre i problemi di osservare ciò
che gli altri non vedono e di vedere ciò
che gli altri scelgono di non vedere ed
ecco dunque un primo aspetto
quelli che vedete qui sopra sono i
risultati di un'analisi big data
condotta su più di 7 milioni di pazienti
se tracciamo il percorso da casa alla
struttura sanitaria per ognuno di essi
scopriamo come ognuno percorre ben 48 km
mediamente ovvero spende 58 minuti solo
per il trasporto se volete 32 euro di
spesa ora ci convertiamo questi valori
individuali su una scala globale di più
di 3 milioni di prestazioni che
sosteniamo annualmente otteniamo una
spesa complessiva di 96 milioni di euro
solo per il trasporto
che se volete fatto non secondario
induce un'emissione di anidride
carbonica nell'atmosfera di ben 23 mila
tonnellate di co2
ora se applichiamo questo approccio
innovativo offerto dalla medicina di
prossimità per consentire a questi
pazienti di effettuare le proprie
prestazioni
direttamente da casa o dal posto di
lavoro o dalla farmacia sotto casa
gran parte del tempo e della spesa
sostenuta dai cittadini potrebbe essere
proficuamente risparmiato ed
efficientato inoltre ciò che abbiamo
rilevato e che dalla prospettiva del
paziente la telemedicina e sai ben
percepita in termini di fiducia e di
sicurezza nell'essere costantemente
seguiti e assistiti da qualunque luogo
in qualsiasi momento e soprattutto
saltando le tradizionali e code d'attesa
secondo aspetto come tutte le attività
digitali anche la capacità di
misurazione di parametri vitali è per
sua natura reiterabile effettuare
costanti misurazioni significa dunque
potenziare enormemente il valore della
prevenzione sanitaria significa poter
individuare in anticipo situazioni
critiche curabili prima che essi
diventino patologiche o veramente
critiche terzo aspetto siamo in un
momento storico nel quale le tecnologie
di intelligenze artificiali ai
dispositivi medicali radio ti stanno
continuamente sviluppando stanno
diventando via via sempre più
sofisticati e soprattutto applicabili a
domini medicali sempre più ampi se
osserviamo ad esempio il livello di
miniaturizzazione dei sensori possono
essere patch contatto o qualsiasi altro
tipo di sensoristica ci possiamo rendere
conto come siamo veramente vicini a
possedere un vero e proprio laboratorio
diagnostico sempre connesso al nostro
smartphone ma la prospettiva ancora più
interessante è l'incredibile opportunità
che ci viene offerta dall applicazione
delle tecniche dei machine learning ed
intelligenza artificiale su vaste scale
di dati medicali nel poter quindi
derivare insight ed evidenze cliniche
importantissimo
ovvero se volete con questo approccio di
guardare oltre il problema specifico
possiamo con le tecniche di intelligenza
artificiale predire rischi e potenziali
patologie di ciascuna specifica persona
a questo punto vi starete forse
chiedendo e per chiudere ma quanto
effettivamente facile semplice per
ognuno di noi avvalersi di queste
tecnologie e beneficiare dunque del
valore della telemedicina per me il
miglior modo per dimostrarvi tutto ciò e
svelarvi che durante questo top in
realtà mi sono anche sottoposto mediante
un patch che ho qui sulla pelle
un vero e proprio elettrocardiogramma
non che ho mantenuto monitorati i
livelli di pressione arteriosa dio
simmetria di battito cardiaco eccetera
infine quando all'inizio ho soffiato su
questo piccolo tubicino in realtà ho
effettuato un vero e proprio test
spirometrici una spirometria e da ultimo
ho mantenuto costantemente sotto
controllo le mie onde celebrali e attivo
adesso quindi la telemetria live di
tutti questi valori
a questo punto con un pizzico di
ipocondria non mi pare non mi resta che
chiedere se entra in scena il mio medico
personale dice che è qui dietro le
quinte sta costantemente monitorando i
miei valori e chiedergli se sono sano e
va tutto bene
siete rassicurati forse rileverebbe solo
un po di aumento del battito cardiaco
per l'emozione che mi avete trasmesso se
avete apprezzato questo mio tocca